Якщо ви - батьки школярів,
ваше життя - аж ніяк не мед.
Киянка Руслана Башатова - мама восьмикласниці.
Вона досі подумки повертається до конфлікту
з батьківським комітетом, у який також
виявилась залучена дитина. І також
через гроші до шкільного фонду.
- Мені телефонує батьківський комітет, мама,
і говорить… тоді я принципово не дам вам піцу.
Принципово! Я кажу: можете не давати, ми не голодні.
Тоді образу пережила мовчки. Та інцидент у Харкові
спонукав заговорити. Там на шкільному святі
дівчинці не дали торт, бо її батьки принципово
не здавали гроші до шкільного фонду.
Так звана ”справедлива” голова
батьківського комітету довела школярку до сліз.
Київська мама боїться, аби таке не повторилося
з її донькою. Несподівано історію Руслани
почула інша мама.
- Я вам більше скажу, я просто голова батьківського комітету школи
і я знаю, що всі внески…. я завжди говорю,
розмовляю з батьківськими комітетами і я усім
кажу, що всі внески у нас у школі благодійні!
Уже за мить питання так званих ”добровільних”
внесків у фонд 111-ї київської школи переростає
у жваву дискусію.
- Кажуть: а чи всі батьки здали? А я кажу: почекайте,
яка різниця, всі чи не всі? Це було ваше рішення
щось закуповувати. Ви вирішили, ви і закупили,
а я тут до чого?
За новим законом ”Про освіту”, крім держави,
грантів чи, приміром, прибутку від надання в оренду
приміщень, школа може отримувати фінансування
і через добровільні внески, зокрема батьків.
Сума не може бути фіксованою, а лише
рекомендованою. Утім, на практиці все інакше.
Руслана переслала DW переписку в "Вайбері".
Там ні про яке бажання не йдеться.
"Оскільки залишилися гроші з минулого року, то
в цьому році ми за вересень здаємо, як зазвичай,
по 100 гривень (50 гривень фонд класу). Список зараз відправлю".
"Я так розумію, що є батьки, які проти здачі грошей
у фонд школи, охорони, але вибачте, по 50 гривень
на зошити чи хоча б ручку Вірі Іванівні здати можна!!!"
Утім, ця школа не унікальна, каже
громадський активіст Олесь Ярославцев.
Він займається захистом прав учнів та батьків,
тож скарги про побори отримує з усієї України.
Дискусії в "Вайбері", а також відео, записане
на телефон чи диктофон, батьки можуть надавати
як докази в суді у справах про здирництво та булінг.
- Гімназія, це Голосіївський район.
Вчителька почала шпиняти дитину через те, що
мама не здає гроші і, як мені мама пояснила, нібито,
знову ж таки ”нібито”, ця вчителька отримує
якісь премії, якщо весь клас охопить.
Але, знов-таки, це нібито. Факт у тому, що булінг є,
дитину почали шпиняти, дитина почала пісятись
уночі й дуже погано почуватися.
В адміністрації багатьох київських шкіл,
зокрема і 111-ї, кажуть, що нині проблем
із державним фінансуванням немає. Рано чи пізно
отримають обіцяні одномісні парти для нової української школи.
Виділяють кошти і на ремонт. Утім, гроші батьків тут
не зайві. На них розфарбували стіни, повісили
жалюзі, оновили патріотичний куточок,
утримують охорону.
- Якщо батьки вирішили купити ці жалюзі
за свій рахунок і прийняли це рішення колегіально - будь ласка.
Про тиск на батьків не чули.
- Якщо є така проблема в класі, то треба звернутись
обов’язково до вчителя, бо вчитель може цього
не знати. А потім, від реакції вчителя, можна
звернутись до директора.
Мама ж 8-класниці перестрахувалася по-своєму:
на прохання дитини річний внесок у 500 гривень
у фонд класу таки здала.